and then the 25 years I've been studying
central banking and competitive
alternative there's never been as much
public attention on the Fed as there is
right now and there's never been such
critical hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV from Las Vegas is Freedom Fest
right now we're talking to Steve
Horowitz an economist at st. Lawrence
University in upstate New York and an
associate of the Mercatus Center at
George Mason University in Fairfax
Virginia Steve thanks for talking about
my pleasure Nick thanks for having me
you are known as one of the pitbulls
online of Austrian economics a school of
economic thought that often gets either
ignored completely or pilloried when it
is paid attention to why is austrian
economics on on the rise that it's at
least being attacked one yeah I think
there's a couple reasons I think one
libertarianism in general is on the rise
you can see from you know a couple
thousand people here and and the kind of
attention that that were libertarianism
in general has been getting in the last
few years and so Austrian economics
associated with that in a variety of
ways I think gets the attention but I
think the other reason is is that the
Austrians actually have an explanation
of where we've been the last give us a
quick thumbnail of what Austrian
economics is and how it is really you
know counter to both you know a
monetarist school said which most people
are probably familiar with or a
Keynesian model well if we think in
terms of macroeconomics I think the big
key is that for for Austrians Austrians
are less concerned about sort of
economic aggregates in both the
monetarist and the Keynesian czar for
Austrians the key to what we think of as
macroeconomics is understanding the way
in which money affects individual prices
and interest rates and thereby distorts
the coordination of economic activities
right right so so for example in the
last few years we saw the Fed engaged in
the expansion of the money supply
driving interest rates down low
generating the boom of the 2000s then
leading to the busts that we've seen
more recently when people take issue
with Austrian economics they typically
say look these are people we've never
heard of so they can't be important or
that you know they're talking about a
world in which people would compete over
currency use I mean there would be no
monopoly on money this is all pie in the
sky why is Austrian economics
relevant in a world of central banks and
of government Fiat lot well I think
because they've screwed up so massively
I mean what we've seen is the Fed both
cause of this crisis and then expand its
powers enormously in the last few years
and be unable to resolve it and so I
think we've in the 25 years I've been
studying central banking and competitive
alternatives there's never been as much
public attention on the Fed as there is
right now and there's never been such
critical attention basically what you're
saying is there isn't enough money that
the Fed could pump into the monetary
supply to actually change what's wrong
with the economy well that's right and
we've seen it I mean we've seen the Fed
expand almost triple the monetary base
in the last few years and the banks are
just sitting on it one reason is the
feds paying interest on reserves but
another reason is the banks don't think
the lending opportunities are out there
so it's in to use the old expressions
pushing on a string so and I mean this
is something that's I find very
interesting is that you know free-market
critics of Keynesian stimulus a theory
will say you know Keynes ins are always
gonna say oh just make it twice as big
three times as big four times to speak
there's something similar on the monitor
aside right right they say you know if
the economy has some restored it's
because we haven't pumped enough money
in how do you get out of that
epistemological you know yeah it's in
some sense it's unfalsifiable right I
mean there's just we it's all
counterfactuals one way or the other and
I think what Austrians and others need
to do is to be tell the best story we
can about why we think that's not going
to happen and why what some of the
long-run unintended consequences of that
might be when you want to empower the
Fed to do those things you give it a
whole bunch of new powers that you know
it's just not going to give up well what
from a Austrian point of view if I mean
let's say Austrians get in charge of the
Fed obviously the first thing they do is
disband it yeah what's the second thing
they do I mean realistically what is the
policy prescription that emanates from
an Austrian prospect I think with
respect to monetary policy at least
anyway
yeah I mean you got to close the Fed you
got a real eagle-eyes the public use of
gold or other commodities as money you
have to also get rid of some old laws
that prevent banks from issuing their
own notes and routine make those
redeemable in gold so there's two
problems you had n the monopolies that
the Fed has but you also have to create
the conditions for competition among
banks to produce a more stable currency
let's switch gears you write a lot about
the family yeah like a little bit
work on that because and you know
libertarianism writ large is often seen
as anti-family or indifferent to family
units as opposed to individuals well I
think there's a couple of things that
I've been doing in my work one is to
sort of document historically the way in
which capitalism and industrialization
produced what we think of as the modern
family and that this poses an
interesting dilemma for people on the
left and the right right that on the
left who love the sort of scope for
choice that people now have over the
kinds of families they they create and
what they do with them I want to argue
that it was capitalism that made that
possible
but both through opening up economic
freedom but the wealth that created -
and conversely on the right and if I can
also I mean Mises talks about this as
various points that the contractual
marriage is essentially part of the
liberal project that as opposed to
that's something else and it was it was
when marriage became contractual that
was empowering of women in a way had
never been the case before exactly and
of course on the right right if folks
who at least pay lip service to
capitalism and the dynamism of the
economy but don't like the cultural
change that it generates right and so
for them that you know but what my
response is you can't put that
toothpaste back in the tube
once you've unleashed the the dynamism
of the marketplace you're gonna get
dynamic you know and this is people on
the right people like charles Murray and
ourself to find libertarian says you
know what we have an unsustainable
family issue here where so many people
are being born out of wedlock
you know it's screwed and you see the
cognates of that on the left as well is
that all capitalism's fault there's two
things going at once you have the sort
of long-run secular forces of increase
in wealth that have made single
parenthood possible but you certainly
have damaging policies and especially
the tax code and other sorts of things
that have made it more worth people's
while not to marry and one of the things
I'm trying to argue in this work is that
marriage and family are still important
we just need to be more open and more
flexible about how we about how we
define those things this is something
that often gets leveled against
libertarians so it's you know it's a
relativism run amok I mean is there
something wrong with a single-parent
family there's not I mean what I think
is clear from the research is that all
of the things equal to parents you know
who who are taking care of a child is
better than the alternative
but when everything else is in equal and
a dysfunctional two-parent family is not
as good as a functional single-parent
family or we can make the same argument
saying sex couples versus versus let's
leads in
another project that you're involved in
the group of self self defined group
bleeding-heart libertarians and
libertarians are often seen as
incredibly austere people again who
don't care about groups or you know
social welfare except for me talk about
bleeding hearts liberty bleeding heart
libertarians what's its ethos and what
are you trying to accomplish I think
there's two things going on at once
there one at the philosophical level is
an attempt by many to sort of blend
Hayek and Rawls for lack of a better
term which to say and we're talking
about Lou Rawls - yes we want to see me
Ohioans into the rhythm but John Rawls
was the John Rawls of Spock applause
yeah yeah I think the I think the idea
there simply is to say that no Rawls his
argument was that social institutions
are justified by the extent to they work
that they work to the benefit of the
least well-off in society and I think
the construction that for many of those
philosophically oriented is to how might
libertarianism meet those without those
criteria does can we justify morally
justified libertarianism on the grounds
that it actually does do better off but
better by the least well-off than other
systems well I I mean isn't that just
self-evidently false no and I'm taking
the point of view of a critic would say
no we know that because we know when Ron
Paul says in a Republican Party debate
or a presidential debate yeah if a guy
doesn't have health insurance nobody
should have to treat him so you would
you know libertarians would rather see
people die in the streets then help them
right well I think there's a difference
between saying nobody has to treat him
and then asking the question what has
what you know how much has the standard
of care risen over 200 years
how much is even a poor American today
able to procure medical care outside of
those kinds of systems and so look at
you think of Deirdre McCloskey work here
arguing the way in which throughout
economic history growth and
industrialization have benefited not
just the wealthy but especially the poor
and there's all kinds of interesting
data on the sort of average American
family today versus a generation ago or
a century ago that we can look at I
think there's also on the bleeding heart
liberals project there's a more less
philosophical idea which is simply this
notion that libertarians ought to be
talking more about how our policies
benefit the least well-off
and not falling into those kind of traps
that Ron Paul kind of fell into there
which is - let's let's focus our
rhetoric and our language and the way we
think about issues on explaining how
libertarianism
can can can address the concerns of many
on the left and do so more effectively
than their own policies what's the best
place to read about bleeding hearts
liver turn bleeding heart libertarianism
dot-com is the blog and there's it's
very active all kinds of things going on
there alright well Steve Horowitz of st.
Lawrence University of the Mercatus
Center of bleeding heart libertarians
thanks for talking to Reason - my
pleasure Nick thank you Nicholas